Originally, starting with you, I had been taking a D3 plus K2 product that I had and you said
I should continue taking it. I used that product up and I'm wondering about the D3 K2 product
that you sell. Okay, I'm going to use this as an example. So, first of all, this is the right
thing to do ask me. So, what I like, my favorite D3 product is our D3 complete, oh, it's called ADK
complete because it's all the fat soluble vitamins in one thing. So, the ADK complete gives you
5,000 I use a vitamin D, vitamin K, vitamin E in the delta-tocol tree at all form. So, I think that's
the best one out there. I'm using this as an example, as we just had somebody this morning or
last night, purchased the cell core brand. And cell core just came out with a D3 K2 and of course,
cell core, everything cell core has also has phobic and cubic acid in it. And somebody, one of our patients,
who we haven't spoken to for a while, purchased that. And I have to call, I have to tell Megan,
to call her and say, that's not what I would use. I mean, cell core is great for products,
but it doesn't mean that their D3 K2 would be my recommend, I'm never going to recommend that to
patients. Of course, the protests were there by me, but just from a knowledge base, I wouldn't
recommend that. So, I'd recommend that ADK complete for your D products because it has all your fat
soluble supplements in it. Regarding the ADK complete product, would I follow DOSID recommended
in the product? I would take at least one a day if you're stable and you're doing well,
I would just do one a day, that's 5,000 I use a day. And I would base it upon your blood test of
your vitamin D level. If your vitamin D level is below 80, then I would probably take two a day
until you could get it over 80. And then you could go back to one a day. If your vitamin D level is
150, then I wouldn't take it at all. You really want to keep your vitamin D levels between 80 and 150.
For a person with a history of cancer, anybody else, don't have cancer. Still, I think your vitamin D level
should be 50 to 150. But you'd base that on your blood work.